ஒரு உண்மையான விஷயமா, இல்லை ஒரு விஷயமா, இல்லை ஒரு விஷயமா, இல்லை ஒரு விஷயமா, இல்லை ஒரு விஷயமா, இல்லை ஒரு விஷயமா, இல்லை ஒரு விஷயமா, இல்லை ஒரு விஷயமா, இல்லை ஒரு விஷயம் அமைக்கப்பட்ட ஒரு கோட்பாடா,
எதுக்கு அது மாதிரி அதிகமா வருகிறது அப்படின்னா, மனிஷ்யனுக்கு வாழ்க்கையில் வந்து கஷ்டமே இல்லாமல் இருக்கானா எதைப்பற்றினே கவலைப்படாமா வாழ்ந்துட்டு போறும் அவன்,
யாரைப் பற்றியும் கவலைப்படாமல் அவன் பாட்டா வாழ்க்கையில் வாழ்ந்துட்டு போறும் அவனுக்கு கஷ்டம் என்னும் வரும்போது தான் கடவுளைத் தேடிப் போறு, ஏன் எனக்குத் தான் இப்படி ஆகுது, இது மாதிரி விஷயங்கள் எல்லாம் நடக்குது,
அப்படி பார்க்கும்போது, கர்மா ஒருவனை சந்தோஷமா வைச்சியிருக்குன்னும்போது, அவன் எதைப் பத்தியுமே கவலைப்படாமல், இறவனை இறவன் நோக்கிப் போறுத்துதான் நம்முடைய வாழ்க்கையுடைய பிறந்ததுக்கான காரணம் அப்படின்னா, அந்த ஒரு செயலில் கூட இயிடுப்படாமா வாழ்க்கை வாழ்ந்துட
கர்மா என்றது வந்து அவனுடைய வாழ்க்கையோடன் நோக்கரத்தை அவனுக்குப் புரியவைச்சு, அவன் எப்படி வானுன்றத்தை அவனுக்குச் சொல்வத்து கான ஒரு அமைப்பு தானா, அது உண்மை தானா.
இல்லை நம்ம அது மாதிரி ஒன்று கிடையாது, ஆனா வாழ்க்கையில நடக்குற விஷயங்களை எப்படி நம்ம ஏற்றுக்கொண்டு
இல்லை, நம்ம் அது மாதிரி ஒன்று கிடையாது, ஆனா வாழ்க்கையில் நடக்கும் விஷயங்களை எப்படி நம்மே ஏற்றுக்கொண்டு, நம்ம் இந்த வாழ்க்கை ஒன்றும் சிறப்பாக அமைத்துக்கொள்ள வேண்டும் என்றதுக்காக அமைக்கப்பட்ட ஒரு கொடுப்பாட.
ஒரு அவ்வின், அவ்வின் மாதிரி, சரி, மிகவும் சரியான கேள்விதார். ஆனால் நான் என்ன சொல்கிறேன், இது நீங்கள் சொன்னால் மாதிரி சரியான,
ஒரு மனித்தினை இன்னும் சந்தோஷமா வாழ வைப்பதற்கு அவனுக்குக் கிடைக்கக்கொள்ளுய சப்பிரிகிசாவுந்து, அவனே எதுவொரு வாங்கையில் ஜெஸ்டிவாய் பண்ணி, அதிலிருந்து வெடியும் வரத்துக்கு ஒரு காணச்செட்ட ஐடியா.
அது கடவுளைப் பற்றி கூட அர்த்தி சொல்ல தான் கடவுள் என்பது ஒரு கான்செட்டு அப்படின்னு சொல்லவார்கள் இருக்கான்னு
கடவுள் முன்னும் கிடையாது ஒரு கான்செட்டு
நமக்கு ஒரு லீகலா, லாவ வெய்டிங்கா, நல்லது செய்யவேண்டும் ஒரு எண்ணத்தோட, பயந்து வாழ்வதற்கு ஒரு கான்செட்டு
நீங்க அந்தப் பொன்னு, கங்கா சசீதரன் வைலின் வாசிக்கதைக் கேளு, பயினொரு வயது இப்போது
எனக்கு தெரிந்து மூன்று, நாளு வருஷமாக வைலின் வாசிக்கிறான், நான் யூட்டியூபில் கேட்டுக்கொண்டு இருக்கிறேன்
கங்கா சசீதரன்